- So, wait, you are about to
be, this is literally my kids',
like one of their favorite
characters all the time
is Ursula, and you're about to do this
in the live action "The Little Mermaid".
- Yes.
- Are you so stoked? I mean,
you have the best song,
"Poor Unfortunate Souls", yeah.
- It's so weird because
when I was a nanny,
I worked for this lovely,
the Ross family, hi Rosses!
And we watched "The Little
Mermaid" almost every night.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I truly was like, for
three years I watched it
almost every night.
- Yeah.
- And to get to play it and to work with,
like, Rob Marshall.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And just the whole,
because I don't get to be in your world,
of like singing and sliding
down a clamshell, and.
- [Kelly] I know.
- Truly. The clamshell was like, you know,
the size of a house, I was like.
- I know but you have the best song!
Did you feel so powerful
singing that song?
- I was scared to death.
And then I worked with somebody,
and then I was like, okay,
it's just a character.
I don't have to be, I
don't have to be a singer.
I can just be this character.
But I love that song.
And when it.
- Me too.
- When we finally recorded
it and they're like,
that's it, you've got your song.
I literally burst out
crying 'cause I was like,
I don't get to go to
singing class anymore.
Like, that's it?
- You don't get to go to
singing class, that's hilarious.
- It'd be weird if you kept,
if you kept going it would be odd.
- That would be weird.
Not your Friday night dress
up in a box of chocolates?
I was like, that's your line?
- That's mine.
- [Kelly] We found it.
Yeah, I was like, okay.